buonasera a tutti e tutti non vi vedo
purtroppo e sono molto grato di questa
opportunità anche a chi ha organizzato
perché posso condividere con voi non
solo di ciò di cui mi occupo
professionalmente ma ciò che è lampo la
mia passione come cittadino cioè il
ruolo di noi cittadini rispetto alle
scelte importanti che dobbiamo fare nel
mondo contemporaneo
e allora siccome faccio il prof comincia
con l'indovinello non è un
interrogazione qual è quel paese membro
della ue
comincia per i che recentemente ha
introdotto i matrimoni gay irlanda brava
qualcuno avrà pensato l'italia noi non
abbiamo introdotto i matrimoni gay vero
e va bene l'irlanda i media hanno
parlato molto di questo perché un paese
cattolicissimo no l'irlanda è un anno fa
circa l'ottanta per cento degli
irlandesi in un referendum ha provato
questa innovazione
cosa è successo però i media non ci
hanno detto che questa era il l'esito
finale di un lungo processo avviato un
paio d'anni prima dal parlamento
irlandese tali politiche che hanno preso
atto della crisi profonda che dal 2008
attraversava l'economia e la politica
irlandese ha detto dobbiamo cercare un
altro sistema per cambiare la nostra
posizione che risale al 1937 e hanno
avviato quello che si chiama una
convention on the constitution
potete anche guardare il sito sedi
interessa come era composto 199
partecipanti 66 erano cittadini comuni
un uomo e una donna per ogni collegio
elettorale d'irlanda che per un anno si
sono incontrati a volte al mese insieme
a 33 parlamentari la metà in minoranza e
quindi attorno a tavoli con facilitatori
ascoltando opinioni diverse anche
contrastanti su dieci temi
non solo i matrimoni omosessuali il
reato di blasfemia che era nella
costituzione irlandese quanto deve stare
in carica del presidente della
repubblica il sistema udite udite il
sistema elettorale dell'irlanda
ogni volta hanno redatto il rapporto
delle volte con opinioni diverse le
hanno mandate al governo e al parlamento
e in alcuni casi sono in tenuti con
leggi ordinarie
altre volte con referendum come questo e
che ho citato ma nessuno ha detto che
contemporamente gli irlandesi hanno
votato per l'età minima del presidente
repubblicano che siano diciamo così più
tecnica e hanno detto va bene così
quindi i cittadini irlandesi hanno
saputo distinguere e perché
perché questo processo li aveva come
dire data la possibilità di informarsi
di valutare di soppesare per bene le
loro posizioni
el 80 per cento ha votato per i
matrimoni omosessuali
bene questo ci porta al punto dove
voglio arrivare
e cioè la democrazia sta di salute
beh mica tanto bene se guardate questa
rilevazione che è stata fatta fra buon
numero di paesi a democrazia
rappresentativa
vedete che solo il 40 per cento in media
dei cittadini dei paesi democratici
pensa che la democrazia sia
assolutamente importante cioè meno della
metà non abbiamo tanto bene cosa dite e
la democrazia come sapete è una creatura
quindi piuttosto fragile anche rara
nella storia dell'umanità quand'è che a
polis greca alcuni comuni medievali
italiani avevano forme di autogoverno e
poi la fine settecento la rivoluzione
francese americana che introducono un
altro tipo di democrazia quella basata
sulla rappresentanza
giusto la giustificazione era che
siccome le distanza la scala dei paesi
moderna francia l'america non si poteva
più partecipare come l'anti catene ma
era anche un modo per far sì che a
governare fossero i cosiddetti migliori
cioè le élite mica tanto democratico
bene allora oggi la democrazia vivono
una situazione paradossale per un verso
è la forma egemonica di governo nel
pianeta circa il 60 per cento dei paesi
godono delle libertà politiche connesse
alla democrazia ma per l'altro verso
sappiamo bene che la democrazia è stata
versando una crisi di parolina chiave
fiducia questa è una rivelazione
rilevazione scusate fra i paesi della ue
e vedete che non solo il livello di
fiducia nella ue e nelle istituzioni
nazionali
parlamento e governo è basso ma è anche
decrescente in calo un segnale piuttosto
preciso allora in particolare sono in
crisi i due canali partecipativi su cui
si fonda la democrazia rappresentativa
elezioni alle ultime elezioni aggiorna
in emilia romagna votato il 37 per cento
e i partiti politici nessuno si scrive
più a un partito e non solo in italia
bene quindi se questa è la situazione
i regimi sono la democrazia a un bivio
da una parte c'è una strada che si
chiama meno democrazia la democrazia
ridotta spettacolo mediatico a prendere
decisioni sono soggetti come
multinazionali la finanza globale la
criminalità organizzata non
sottovalutate le aziende informatiche e
c'è il rischio come dire che ci rimanga
solo il guscio esterno della democrazia
ma la sostanza la polpa de chi ha potere
di chi decide
l'altra strada si chiama più democrazia
diceva molto tempo fa un signore che si
chiamava john dewey che i mali della
democrazia si cono con più democrazia
allora più democrazia significa
coinvolgerci di cittadini cioè la
partecipazione ora vi chiedo che cos'è
la partecipazione
ognuno pensi dentro di sé magari un
attimo e proviamo affidarci a questo
signore che cantava la libertà è
partecipazione e diceva una cosa molto
vera libertà politiche le partecipazioni
e democrazia sono strettamente connesse
però non ci dà una risposta
soddisfacente perché oggi se pensiamo a
partecipazione non sappiamo bene cosa
sia sociale politiche all'assemblea
bene allora io vorrei provare a
prospettare un tipo di partecipazione un
modo di declinarla molto precisa che è
frutto della convergenza di tre matrici
di cultura politica una che viene al sud
america non è che viene dal mondo
anglosassone è uno che viene da alcuni
paesi il nord europa come la danimarca
la germania e questi tre queste tre
matrici culturali si sono fusi in quelle
che oggi si chiama partecipazione
deliberativa e cerco di farvi
intravedere come questa sia diversa dai
modi usuali di intendere la
partecipazione politica
vediamoli una volta inclusione bella
parola molto in uso che significa
significa chi partecipa generalmente a
partecipare solo che gli stakeholders i
gruppi di interesse organizzate le
amministrazioni pubbliche consultano
sempre questi soggetti domanda non hanno
mica un mandato democratico
forse una forma di corporativismo più
che di democrazia
l'altra opzione sarebbe coinvolge il
demos il popolo i cittadini semplici per
così dire come hanno fatto in irlanda
l'altra questione si coinvolgiamo i
cittadini semplice come li scegliamo
modo usuale
si annuncia una riunione un'assemblea
chi vuole viene e chi viene
i soliti noti i cittadini attivi ottime
persone ma che rappresentano solo se
stesse o quelli molto preoccupati di una
specifica decisione ma anche la voce
della collettività di una comunità nel
suo insieme
come possiamo ottenere questo attraverso
il campionamento noi usiamo il
campionamento
da quasi un secolo da quando gallop
inventò i sondaggi e crediamo ai
risultati dei sondaggi lusia usiamo il
campionamento in moltissime altre
attività ma in politica questa cosa non
suona mica tanto bene
eppure il sorteggio è stato utilizzato
sia nella polis greche che nei comuni
medievali italiani e perché perché
l'idea era che l'unico modo di impedire
agli aristocratici ai nobili ai ricchi
ai potenti di occupare le cariche
pubbliche sia quello di consentire a
tutti di farlo e nella polis greca
davano un compenso giornaliero da ogni
cittadino che ricopriva una carica
pubblica perché questa era l'unico modo
di rendere possibile che lasciasse
trascurassi suoi affari privati per
dedicarsi alla cosa pubblica
secondo secondo caratteristica di
informazione noi abbiamo opinioni ma
sono grezze cerchiamo di elevare il
livello di informazione siamo una
società molto sofisticata quindi
incorporiamo dati conoscenze ma anche
preferenze sociali che sono complesse
articolate siamo una società plurale ed
eterogenea ognuno di noi vuole molte
cose anche in contrasto tra di loro se
ci pensate
l'altra sfida è gettare dei ponti tra
che tra i saperi dei cittadini comuni e
saperi esperti non vogliamo buttare gli
esperti fra finestra ma non gli
deleghiamo scelte sono di carattere
valoriale su cui solo noi possiamo
sceglie volete il nucleare o no lo
facciamo decidere ai fisici nucleari o
decidiamo noi cittadini i rischi che
vogliamo correre un esempio di ponte di
questo tipo ce l'ha offerto genova
questo è il viadotto morandi sopra il
torrente polcevera otto anni fa la
sindaca donna notate bene dice basta
sono vent'anni che questa autostrada
intasata non se ne esce coi soliti
meccanismi proviamo qualcosa di nuovo
prendiamo il dibattito pubblico che
usano in francia dagli anni 90 e
facciamolo su questa vicenda qui società
autostrada arriva con cinque tracciati e
i cittadini ne propongono sesto molto
meno impattante
la società autostrade l'accetta in altre
parole la creatività dei cittadini i
loro saperi la conoscenza dei luoghi gli
ha permesso di arrivare a una decisione
migliore
dialogo significa ascolto ma perché ci
si ascolta e rispetto della diversità di
opinioni bravate che la diversità non è
il problema la diversità è la nostra
ricchezza
per arrivare a questo cosa dobbiamo fare
creare un clima appropriato si usano dei
metodi e wall caffè lost qualcuno qui ha
mai fatto nosto un gol caffè o un town
meeting manine qualche manina c'è quindi
sapete cosa sto parlando
attenzione però che non ci fermiamo alla
forma del formato leopolda qualcuno l'ha
chiamata no non basta dei tavolini col
facilitatore c'è dell'altro come vedrete
tutto questo serve a soppesare
deliberazione non significa a decidere
significa bilancia soppesare cosa i vari
polsi d'azione e le loro implicazioni e
poi decidere in che modo in maniera
possibilmente condivisa consensuale
cercare accordi se ci ascoltiamo capiamo
le nostre differenze perché siamo
diversi forse possiamo trovare un
terreno condiviso tutto questo però
comporta che cosa una restituzione del
potere a chi al popolo sovrano articolo
1 della costituzione italiana
non dimentichiamo sempre il popolo è
sovrano però dice salvo poi che nelle
forme e nella nostra costituzione
stabilita dalla legge e quindi ce
l'hanno già tolto il potere
questa è la scala della partecipazione
molto spesso la partecipazione alla
prima livello l'amministrazione fa una
bella storia ti informa di ciò che ha
già deciso
oppure consultazione consulto chi i
gruppi di interesse saliamo questi
gradini condividiamo il potere fra
cittadini e governanti o in alcuni casi
deleghiamo la scelta ai cittadini
esempio di paolo di bilancio partecipato
non avrete sentito parlare tutti al sito
paradis portalegre fine anni 80 ha avuto
un enorme successo migliaia di comuni al
mondo fanno bp
questo esempio di lire dall'india
migliaia di contadini con scarsi livelli
di istruzione hanno discusso di come
usare le scarse risorse finanziarie che
avevano nel kerala sud dell'india prima
si è parlato il cambiamento climatico il
primo processo partecipativo
deliberativo globale avvenuto nel 2009
in vista del summit di copenaghen che
citava prima luca lombroso il worldwide
views on global warming in vista del
summit di copenaghen 36 cittadini
campionati 36 paese il mondo compresa
l'italia
hubble qui a bologna l'abbiamo fatto
hanno parlato il cambiamento climatico e
mandato le loro i loro input a
copenaghen tecnologie nostre vite pt che
oggi abbiamo sento parla di internet
stamattina eccetera bello le tecnologie
possono essere buone o cattive
vogliamo parlarne vogliamo valutare
prima che entra nella nostra vita
i danesi l'hanno fatta il technology
assessment in danimarca si fa coi
cittadini che ascolto gli esperti di
vario orientamento ne discutono e poi
presentano le loro considerazioni al
paese ai miti e al parlamento danese
attraverso un format in si chiama
consensus conference sistema elettorale
altri temi che ci riguarda l'italia e
discutiamo da un pezzo
il problema è che i partiti non si
metteranno mai d'accordo perché grandi
partiti hanno interessi completamente
diversi da quelli piccoli
lì la discussione solo partigiano e
strumentale british columbia provincia
del canada 160 cittadini un uomo e una
donna ad ogni collegio elettorale hanno
discusso per un anno di sistemi
elettorali sono diventati esperti hanno
proposto un sistema e che è andata a
referendum il 57 per cento dei cittadini
di questa provincia ha votato a favore
di quella loro proposta fatta da loro
pari
disastri naturali anche qui i terremoti
calamità in italia non mancano si
possono affrontare coinvolgendo i
cittadini twin towers a new york come
ricostruirle ne hanno discusso 2000
cittadini materno
parenti delle vittime inventarono
cittadini sorteggiati e o quello che
vedete oggi a new york è il risultato di
questo processo
new orleans finito sotto le acque di
catherine il piano di ricostruzione
discusso coi cittadini o leenstra l'auto
dispersi per tutti gli stati uniti
grazie all'informatica tutti hanno
potuto discutere e lavorare i piani di
ricostruzione
alcuni di questi processi sono stati
promossi dal passo non solo dalle
istituzioni in australia in belgio
proprio per rispondere alla crisi di
legittimazione della politica e gilet in
belgio no invece del g20 mille cittadini
non è utopia e non è solo all'estero
la toscana ha fatto una bellissima legge
che incorpora questi principi nel 2007 e
grazie a un sostanzioso finanziamento
700 mila euro all'anno la partecipazione
costa qualcosa ma meno forse della
politica istituzionale hanno discorso
hanno fatto oltre cento processi
partecipativi in questi giorni si è
parlato dei referendum inglese in
colombia che han dato esiti ci hanno
lasciato un po sbigottiti no se avessero
fatto come fa lo stato dell'oregon dove
un gruppo di cittadini estratti a sorte
discute le questioni che vanno al
referendum pubblico un depliant che va
in tutte le case i cittadini votano è
stato misurato scientificamente in
maniera molto più consapevoli informata
di quanto non si faccia oggi forse il
referendum che farà cui andremo i 4
dicembre
beh questo forse ci avrebbe aiutato un
po a scegliere meglio chiusa diete per
finire i cittadini e sono ignoranti non
sono interessati e stiamo la risposta al
grande politologo italiano di 500 anni
fa che disse quanta la prudenza e la
stabilità dico come un popolo è più
prudente più stabili e di miglior
giudizio che un principe se l'ha detto
l'autore del principe forse merita di
essere preso in considerazione
grazie